[Music]
the santa claus is one of the most
frequently discussed movies in the whole
christmas canon that's partly because
when you look at it closely some of its
details actually seem kind of bizarre
nonsensical or even downright disturbing
here are some things kids might not
notice about this modern holiday classic
the central conceit of the santa claus
is that if something bad happens to
santa the next person who puts on his
suit will inherit his title
of course the movie works well as a
comedy because the person who happens to
do that scott calvin doesn't want to be
santa at all but is guilted into putting
on the suit by his young
son charlie inevitably the magic and
spirit of christmas eventually went
scott over but not until after a
considerable struggle that struggle is
the heart of the film but this all
raises one unsettling question
what does someone terrible had put on
that suit scott can be kind of a jerk
but he's still a pretty decent person
what if a hardened criminal had gotten
their hands on the suit and put it on
say as a disguise
what if they'd ignored or never even
seen the reindeer what is someone who
killed santa intentionally rather than
accidentally
fell subject to the claws honestly it's
a very poorly thought out system
troubling contractual issues aside scott
does put on the suit and manages to
bumble his way through delivering a few
gifts with charlie before the reindeer
take them back to the north pole
once there he's greeted by well by
absolutely nothing the reindeer simply
run away to their stables for the night
before an elf shows up and without
saying a word puts in a code to make the
slate ascend into santa's headquarters
the rest of the elves then basically
ignore their new boss as he hops out of
the sleigh and starts asking questions
when head elf bernard finally does talk
to scott he seems annoyed that he even
has to fill the new guy in
and the rest of the elves appear neither
pleased nor concerned to see the new
santa walking around like a deer in
headlights
what's even more concerning is that none
of the elves seemed to care at all that
the old santa just died and vanished
into nothingness
did they really hate their old boss that
much does this happen all the time so
they just don't get attached
everyone knows the north pole is
supposed to be cold but geez
speaking of the old santa the film never
once stops to address his past life or
legacy at the north pole
we don't know if he was a particularly
good or bad santa we don't know how long
he was on the job
we don't even know how well he got along
with the elves this stuff is obviously
brushed over so the film can get on with
scott's story but the santa claus 2
suggests that it's hugely important for
santa to get married
and even eventually begin a family did
the last santa do those things
if so what happened to his mrs claus is
she long dead
did she retire from the north pole upon
his death or was he too new on the job
to even contemplate that
these are all things the story ignores
in favor of a plot contrivance that
allows an ordinary guy to become santa
after the old one is defeated by a
slippery rooftop but something still
doesn't add up here
the santa claus is a relatively short
movie and it's not until the sequels
that you're given a better look at the
whole mythology of the north pole and
the people who populate it
while the movies never explain however
is just where the actual santa claus
comes from when scott returns in the
sleigh bernard and the other elves don't
seem all that surprised that they have
to train a new santa which suggests this
isn't the first time a father christmas
has died on the job
nobody explains how long the contract
has been around but it's fair to say
that it's probably very
very old meaning the mantle of santa
claus has been changing hands for some
time
so who actually wrote this contract how
did it become hidden in the fine print
to that little card
who nailed down the technicalities does
the north pole have a legal department
clearly this thing exists because santa
needed to be replaced one time and the
elves realized that they had to create a
legal precedent for getting a new one
but the exact details as to how this
came about are sadly never revealed
once scott arrives at the north pole and
finally gets a little explanation from
bernard the head elf seems to decide to
calm him down rather than bombard him
with too many details
which is fair enough of course so
bernard sends scott to his room to get
some rest
judy will take you to your room and get
out of the suit it needs to be cleaned
and taken in then get some sleep we've
got a lot of work to do and only a year
in which to do it
sleep on it and you'll learn more later
seems like a fair attitude to take with
a panicked new employee but scott
actually wakes up in his own bed at home
with no memory of how he got there and
more importantly no further instructions
from the north pole so like anyone would
he writes it off as a weird dream
but then his body starts to change
proving that his trip to the north pole
really happened
even then however there's still no word
from the elves the first real contact he
receives from bernard is the list in the
form of thousands of packages stacked
throughout his house
after that things only get more manic so
much for easing the poor guy in
scott calvin initially dismisses his
role as the new santa is nothing more
than a weird dream but he soon finds
that ignoring his new role has some
physical consequences
he starts to gain weight literally
overnight his facial hair begins to grow
at a supernatural rate and he develops
an insatiable appetite for dessert foods
when it all gets bad enough scott does
what most people would probably do in
the same situation he goes to his doctor
after a thorough checkup scott's doctor
delivers his patient a healthy dose of
um optimism okay look so what you put on
a little weight
a little weight does this look like a
little weight to you weight
can fluctuate from year to year the
doctor confirms that he can't find
anything medically wrong with scott so
he basically just tells him to go home
eat less and dye his hair now this is
clearly a busy general practitioner who
just wants to calm his patient but you
can't help but wonder why he isn't
digging deeper
and why scott isn't asking him to if
scott had just offered to shave right
there in the office and the doctor
watched the hair literally grow back
he'd be sure to take notice
at the very least he'd get a good
research paper out of it
the santa claus is a film that hinges on
belief and the central conflict involves
charlie's steadfast belief that not only
is santa claus real but that his father
has now become saint nick himself
this creates tragic issues within
charlie's family as his mother laura and
stepfather neil become convinced that
scott is making himself appear to be
santa in order to take charlie away from
them
it also plays the classic christmas
story trope of adults not believing in
santa claus like children do
laura and neil even discuss this while
they recall the exact moments they
stopped believing in santa because they
didn't get the gifts they asked for
i was three and it was an oscar mayer
weenie whistle
here's the problem though the audience
knows that santa is real and that means
these families all wake up on christmas
morning to presents that weren't there
when everyone went to bed but how do the
parents feel about this
is there some strange magic spell that
convinces them they put them there
do they simply forget which presents
they bought and which ones they didn't
are they just confused doesn't matter
that much to the plot but it would have
been nice to get even a throwaway
explanation for this
since the film spent so much time
dealing with the parents beliefs
okay so in case you've never seen this
movie it's probably worth knowing that
some of the elves have jet packs
these elves are known as the effective
liberating flight squad or elves
and they're first called into service
when santa is arrested at lauren neal's
house
now setting aside the idea that a man
who can fit down any chimney somehow
can't do anything about prison bars the
movie's elves with attitude stick raises
a whole new problem for santa and his
north pole crew
this is because the elves staged a very
flashy and not at all covert extraction
of their boss from jail they tell the
cop on duty that they're his worst
nightmare wrap him up in ribbon and
shove a donut in his mouth then they cut
the door off santa cell with some kind
of high tensile tinsel and simply steal
him away
now you've gotta hand it to the elves
for having the forethought to launch
their raid on the one night where the
station is manned by just one cop but
that doesn't clear up the other problems
namely that there's now going to be a
police report and even probably some
surveillance footage depicting a group
of apparent children magically ribboning
up a cop and abducting a guy dressed
like santa that's going to make for some
very weird team meetings once christmas
is over
obviously despite all the weirdness the
santa claus has a happy ending scott
finally accepts his job as the avatar of
christmas joy and flies off to the north
pole having converted neil and laura to
his cause and forged a loving lasting
relationship with his son
what the ending doesn't address however
is what happens to scott calvin the
human
you know the guy with a house and a job
and presumably a series of public
records that include paying taxes having
a driver's license and owning property
later films in the franchise confirmed
that scott still maintains his civilian
identity in some form as he occasionally
arrives in the human world to visit
charlie
but it's never explained how far this
goes he could simply be showing up
introducing himself as charlie's dad and
then going back home
weirder still when scott first meets
bernard the head elf tells him he has 11
months to get his affairs in order does
that mean banish his former self
fake is death or does scott calvin now
exist in this weird in-between world in
which
his identity is maintained only by
diligent paperwork managing elves
these are big questions people at the
very end of the film neil tells charlie
he would make a great psychiatrist one
day
charlie however decides he's going to
walk a different path no
it's a sweet moment if you disregard the
fact that neil is also his family and
charlie just burned the poor man's whole
life's work with that comment
but it's also kind of a weird remark to
make in the context of the film's story
scott became santa because the last
santa died and there are no other humans
present at the north pole
does charlie mean he's going to move up
there and just live among the elves or
does he mean that he's going to wait for
his dad to die and then take over his
santa suit
he's just a kid so he's probably not
really thinking this through but if it's
the former how would his adult life
proceed for him
if it's the latter does he not realize
that his dad is gonna have to die for
him to fulfill his newfound dream
talk about disturbing implications check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one